ja so sollen wir uns also die argumente
um die ohren hauen
sehr gern ich bin 38 vater von zwei
kindern
unsere jüngste tochter ist jetzt gerade
vor zwei wochen auch die welt von 76
jahre alt gewesen der lehrer wirklich
billig unternehmensberater in münchen
seit fünf jahren
und nebenher haben wir neun enkel und
die wir uns kümmern müssen und drei
pferde
ich bin natürlich offen bin ist auf
hinauslaufen sollte dass ich meine
meinung zur ich drücke zu einer anderen
zeit den stück weit die
unterschiedlichen standpunkte zu
verstehen respektvoll sich auszutauschen
aber eben aus dieser eigenen väter plan
sah man raus zu kommen weil es immer
interessant ist die meinungen anderer
zuhören und sich mit denen aus sand zu
setzen
1900 war also ich glaube ich habe schon
eine position die relativ nah an der
allgemeinen linie der der politik in
deutschland ist und bin halt gespannt
was sozusagen argumente sind von dort
wieder sich zu sehen hat die
bundesregierung richtig auf die korona
krise reagiert ja fühlen sie sich in der
korona krise ausreichend und transparent
informiert ja sind die einschränkungen
des öffentlichen lebens zur eindämmung
des corona virus verhältnismäßig ja nein
ich meine es hälfte aufgrund der
erfahrungen die italien vor über nacht
und die china gemacht hat vielleicht
angehalten gegeben die unter deutschen
verhältnissen zu verantworten gewesen
wäre
also es stimmt schon die inspirierte
sache ist die meinen man hätte das nicht
so extrem nachrüsten
ich gebe heute schon sagen ich glaube
deutschland hat im großen und ganzen
schon einen mittelweg gewählt zwischen
dem mal stehen gemacht hat und zu dem
was in italien oder entspannen
es war wirklich ein gewinnen vor allen
dingen deswegen weil man sich natürlich
dieser einen stunde
losgelöst von allen anderen pflichten
unterhalten musste und konnte ich nur
sagen dass du das einfach mal gut tut
auch losgelöst von dieser zufälligen
begegnungen
wer einfach mal gott und die welt oder
in dem fall gegen korona die aktuelle
situation zu diskutieren
ich stehe hier ein ansatzpunkt ich
glaube aber es auch ein stück weit
ha unrealistisch dass das unglück
passiert weiß ich noch nicht mal
geografischen das beispiel welchem land
das vielleicht deutlich besser
funktioniert
weil ich muss man die macht beschränken
das hat man die der macht nicht
zufrieden möglichkeit gegeben
a o das wollte ich mit einem aber
fortsetzen
man hat sich ausreden lassen
man konnte ist eine alte meinung sage
ohne ist darauf anzulegen den anderen zu
überzeugen mit jemanden den man jetzt
notwendigerweise nicht erkannte aber
auch seine gedanken gemacht hat gut
informiert ist man braucht nur darauf zu
hoffen dass die eigenen argumente beim
andern vielleicht ein bisschen wirken
aber was hätte sozusagen ihrer meinung
nach dann die bessere bei andere antwort
oder reaktion sein sollen
ganz einfach jede antwort wäre pure
kaffeesatzleserei überrascht hat mich
die offenen meines gesprächspartners
ich glaube der lacher ist jetzt keiner
der sozusagen über alle möglichkeiten
diametral entgegengesetzte meinungen zu
haben
[Musik]
das ist der zeitwert uns sich zu nehmen
um bedeutendes gespräch zu kommen wie
auch nicht die eigene meinung bringt
teilen das gesellschaftliche
zusammenleben zu tun wenn man mehr
miteinander
wir können mit bestimmtem ich auf die
jüngeren schauen und hoffen dass man es
ihnen nicht so schwer macht damit dass
man sie selbst sich auch entweichen
lässt so wie man uns chancen gegeben hat
[Musik]